welcome to this video playing add Elmo
since this is a guy one-on-one against
me on time like two times i know is
chatting I already don't like that a lot
but ok check for so ok f3 SSS nonsense
Queen H form ok let's see what is doing
with a 5 mm that's not very common
against the sameish good maybe I don't
really know the slide ok so he wants to
try to get quick play against the form
with the night maneuver to d6
interesting so we form it's probably not
well timed
and let's see 95
don't like this position or not look sir
I don't really I don't really have a
good coordination here the night coming
to a 5 is a nuisance don't know I really
don't know what you do here don't get
any big big play on the on the Kings
side
interesting the nights are somewhat tied
tied to one another look before maybe
look before d5 takes night text and yeah
maybe getting rid of some my structural
problems I guess must play 25 or Quincy
eight maybe it will see a truck takes e4
Queen asics try to be tricky possible
okay so he has some possibly c5 but what
I want to do I want to get in a forum or
maybe night F for now just not a forum
maybe first getting getting this night
on only six
maybe ok interesting position
interesting five possibly 95 was my idea
but at the moment I had this look on
before I am that's a really funny piece
it's a it's a bit off side somewhere
after feeding that something wrong with
my position okay I need to get the rooks
connected him ship somewhere to e three
or five
it's going to see for anyway
how do I ever move move pieces here
maybe I need to go back into f3 now this
was very very strange all of that I
didn't really understand this position
to a light square where is he going to a
46 hangs
not quite sure what Queen d7 is doing I
really want to for singing who sigh I
really didn't can go to f2 alone now
this is probably a better idea Queen
takes rook everyone at least it looks
like some coordination in my position it
was really strange game or is a really
strange game it's not not over yet I
wonder about d5 here d 59 txt 5d takes
c6 so always with checks t 595 t 693
check I can take with the porn actually
okay let's let's go for that then before
he blocks it
who I have no idea what's going on here
take c6 and 95 d 16 seems to win I don't
know what his shorty should play now i
also have 24 possibly nite nite is a
queen deform time whining but then it
can take which is not help helping me
night night x so maybe night xe5 d is
six look f 595 though maybe it's a
double attack on f5 and the Queen
so e seven or does something else 97 is
also probably winning Jack I saw this
before but I wasn't sure because of the
time situation you know time is the
problem but maybe I'm breaking through
with Queen f7 anyway 19 seconds also
check check
now he's spending some time
unfortunately and when promoting check
check check check black shell finish on
time yeah this was probably bad for me
pretty sure about that it was an
interesting way to play 94 I didn't know
that at all I didn't know that at all
let's let's gently oops have a look at
this I'm wondering what's this plate no
it wasn't played in sweida room young
last year yeah I don't know it feels
like I'm this does not look right maybe
I need to play a somewhat somewhat else
and know where i felt i'm in them in
trouble here this is not what i really
want to do computer is giving black some
edge yeah maybe he should really take on
c5 g7 is something where can I can play
them to prove tough position really
tough position I have some terrible
pieces computer is giving black a slight
edge 0.2 0.3 something like that and
these are nice blockaders now that's at
least okay for black seems to be better
but
here i I really don't know see for
computer likes white him here it's not
not if I've mmm I should probably play
if I'm even earlier I was really not I
really did not know what to do him I
hear g5 winning yeah this position it
looked shaky yeah it really looked shaky
g5 okay who is winning I because of
night xe5 yes okay if I do something
like that is playing this and I'm losing
the house yeah I've helped there was
something off but I didn't really see
what okay he took now I'm maybe halfway
okay again and here c 6 is the calm
suggestion with a slight edge from black
and you know maybe if you give it more
time it it's not really clear 0.6 or
something and here d5 yeah this turns
the tables now why does better the comp
gives 95 is the best defense yeah and
this I saw but well okay i'm winning
joining a piece winning a piece but he's
got two pawns and what my position is
not coordinated it's not easy to win in
a blitz game at least now maybe this is
what he should try this is this is
downright losing I can't take c 5 h I
can take c5 if it's much easier but ok
I'm I have a real talent of making it
difficult it is it is winning quite
quite quite clearly those parts will be
be promoting wow tough game thanks for
watching